ich würde sie so gerne belohnen mit
irgendwas heiterem zum gemeinsamen
abschmunzeln stattdessen müssen wir
schon wieder über Vladimir Putin reden
in der Ukraine läuft gerade richtig
schlecht für ihn und seine Antwort
lautet wenig überraschend Eskalation was
sonst
Putin verkündet die Teilmobilmachung und
droht im Westen einmal mehr mit
Atomwaffen möglicherweise sagen manche
Experten ist das ein Ausdruck von
Schwäche von Verzweiflung was ist aber
nicht weniger beunruhigend macht
erinnere ich daran dass auch unser Land
über diverse zerstörungsmittel verfügt
und den einzelnen Komponenten sind die
moderner als die der NATO
okay
ist jetzt wirklich nur ein
unverbindlicher Tipp aber ich finde wenn
man der Welt mit seinen hypermodernen
Waffen droht sollten nicht gleichzeitig
Festnetz Telefone von 1982 im Bild sein
ja
für die Teile kriegt er bei Bares für
rares nicht mal meine Händlerkarte
300.000 Reservisten will Putin einziehen
und diese Nachricht hat in der
russischen Bevölkerung natürlich sofort
Begeisterungsstürme ausgelöst nach
Putins Rede gestern früh kam es zu einem
Ansturm auf one-tickets viele Flüge aus
Moskau raus sind bereits ausgebucht
was die Russen haben noch Flugzeuge
Glückwunsch ernsthaft Glückwunsch an
alle die so schnell rausgekommen sind
vor einem deutschen Flughafen hätten sie
derzeit noch nicht mal ihr Gepäck
aufgegeben
in ganz Russland haben wieder mutige
Menschen demonstriert hunderte wurden
verhaftet zusammengeschlagen von der
Polizei während Putin in der Ukraine
scheinreferenten veranstaltet unter
Kriegsrecht sollen die Bewohner in vier
geklauten Regionen ab heute sagen wir
mal abstimmen ob sie zu Russland gehören
wollen oder doch lieber zu Russland ich
vermute mal das läuft ähnlich
transparent wie damals auf der Krim die
Transparenz beginnt in diesem Tag mit
gläsernen Urnen geheime Wahlen ziehen
anders aus für die Stimmzettel gibt es
nicht mal Umschläge jede hier sieht was
angekreuzt wurde
praktisch oder wenn man die Adressen
lesen kann geht das noch viel schneller
mit den Verhaftungen ist doch toll
und natürlich werden auch bei den neuen
Referenten ab heute wieder durchsichtige
Uhren eingesetzt da steht dann eine wo
man für den Anschluss an Russland
stimmen kann aber dagegen stimmen geht
natürlich theoretisch auch nur muss man
dann halt am Sibirischen Tiger vorbei
ich habe so eine Ahnung wie es ausgeht
ja leider null Entspannung also in
diesen schlimmen Zeiten übrigens gilt
das auch für die Energiekrise die wir
gerade erleben die Bundesregierung sie
werden es gelesen haben hat Juniper
verstaatlicht herzlichen Glückwunsch der
Hauptgewinn beim Schrottwichteln ja ist
ja so uniper hat den Fehler gemacht zu
50% auf russisches Gas zu setzen und sie
Idioten haben den Fehler gemacht beim
Gas zu 40% auf uniper zu setzen aber
komm sehen wir das Positive jetzt wo
Juniper uns quasi allen gehört ist die
doofe gasumlage jawohl vom Tisch ne was
nicht
trete Habeck jetzt völlig durch oder was
bitte tut er und das hören wir von der
Opposition und das ist der eigentliche
Punkt die Gasanlage muss weg sind wir
denn hier im Fußballstadion oder was ist
das mit Demo muss weg sie sind die muss
weg auf Position komm her du
haben sie gesehen März pöbelt direkt
zurück
ein Niveau aber ist schon ganz lustig
wie auch SPD und FDP den Robert beim
wohlgemerkt gemeinsam Projekt Umlage
schön im Regen stehen lassen von wegen
Jule never walk alone selten ist einer
so Lohn geworden wie der ja also sie
merken es dicke Luft in der
ampelregierung und vor allem zwischen
den Herren Habeck und Lindner hat sich
ordentlich was angestaut ordentlich
verhakt und kein Machtwort von Olaf
Scholz ist die gasumlage für einen
verstaatlichen Konzern jetzt
rechtskonform oder nicht bitte um eine
klare Antwort die
finanzverfassungsrechtlichen Prüfungen
laufen auf Hochtouren
es gibt keine weitere Prüfung sie ist
abgeschlossen
ja wie denn nun alte Regel wenn zwei
sich streiten zahlt der dritte und das
sind in dem Fall leider wir vor allem
Lindner besteht auf gasumlage weil er
sonst das ganze Geld für uniper und Co
aus dem laufenden Bundeshaushalt
bezahlen müsste und dann heißt es doch
fürs nächste Jahr bye bye Schuldenbremse
nicht mit ihm Freunde ich fürchte ja der
Lindner
ist wirklich besessen von dem Thema
Schuldenbremse besessen gib mir mal ein
Beispiel gaspreisdecke der müsste jetzt
sagen Experten ganz schnell kommen um
den deutschen Mittelstand das Handwerk
noch von der Pleitewelle zu retten so
wie das zum Beispiel die Niederländer
machen aber geht nicht bei uns wegen
Schuldenbremse das Thema der nächsten
Wochen wie kriegen wir den Christian
runter von seinem kranken Fetisch
er sieht aus wie ein ganz normaler
Finanzminister doch tief in ihm drin
brodelt eine dunkle Leidenschaft wir
müssen schnellstmöglich zurück zur
Schuldenbremse
Schuldenbremse in diesem Berliner
Darkroom bremst der Junge Sparfuchs
ungehemmt vor sich hin nachts im Schein
der energiesparfunzel den Haushalt
zusammenstreichen bis er quietscht er
fesselt sich an die schwarze Null weil
es kann sehen Sie Publikumsliebling Ross
Antony als Christian Lindner Veronika
Ferres als
ampelkoalitionsvertrag und wie immer
Mister magoo als Olaf Scholz in Fifty
Shades of schwedenbremse er spart uns
richtig durch
geil
schon geil und
ja komm komm er meint ja gut tatsächlich
würde ich Herrn Lindner die Rolle als
sparsame schwäbische Hausfrau die unser
Geld beschützt sogar abnehmen wenn er
nicht gleichzeitig längst mit
Schattenhaushalten und Sondervermögen
jonglieren würde so die
verstaatlichungswelle rollt sie liebe
Zuschauer kaufen sich gerade einen
großen gasimporteur nach dem anderen
warum auch immer und wir schalten
deshalb mal live zur uniper Zentrale in
Düsseldorf wo der Kollege Ulrich von
Heesen heute an einer
Protestkundgebung teilnimmt ich nehme
mal an in seiner Eigenschaft als
wütender Gaskunde nee welche in meiner
Eigenschaft als Eigentümer
die Klitsche ist verstaatlicht das heißt
mir gehört der ganze Bums hier
mein Enkel Marvin und ich wir holen
heute alles raus was geht bei Juniper
bevor der Laden endgültig pleite ist ja
mach hinne Marvin der Fortnite so
komisch geguckt Opa der hat nicht
komisch zu gucken der gehört uns auch
uns gehört hier alles ja nun geh wieder
rein paar gute Sachen holen Fernseher
Schmuck Bargeld sowas
wir müssen uns beeilen Juniper verbrennt
jeden Tag 100 Millionen Euro ganz
aktuell noch mal 7 Milliarden Kredit die
wir dem finnischen Staatskonzern Fortum
zurückzahlen müssen hier die Reaktion
der finnischen Ministerpräsidentin
[Musik]
tja
da würde ich auch tanzen welchen blöden
gefunden hätte der mir den Rotz abkauft
naja wir hatten ja keine Wahl mehr von
diesen uniper ist systemrelevanter hängt
unser kompletter Energiemarkt dran ja
kann sein aber man kann ja trotzdem mal
das Kleingedruckte lesen zusammen mit
Juniper haben wir nämlich kein Witz aus
Versehen auch vier russische
Kohlekraftwerke gekauft
zum Mitschreiben dem deutschen Staat
gehören plötzlich Kohlekraftwerke in
Russland
müssten wir jetzt nicht gegen uns selbst
Sanktionen verhängen
und jetzt mal eine ganz andere Frage
warum sollen eigentlich nur wir
Gaskunden mit der Umlage die Zeche
zahlen
mein Nachbar hat eine Ölheizung ich kann
das Grinsen von der dummen Sau nicht
mehr ertragen
gut ja die gasumlage war halt mit der
heißen Nadel gestrickt das ging nicht
anders ich habe eh das Gefühl und ich
mache mir Sorgen weil der arme Robert
Habeck nur noch Millimeter entfernt ist
von dem amtlichen Burnout die Gefahr
begann
wie heißt das
nein brauchen wir immer noch wie soll
ich sagen
hat sich das gehört habe habe ich
gedacht jetzt bin ich in der Comedy
Sendung gelandet
wie heißt es so schön augen auf bei der
Berufswahl
auch Marvin was hast du da jetzt geholt
du wolltest doch ein Manager der dein
Auto wäscht ah ja stimmt da drüben der
Mercedes und nicht Felgen vergessen
Freundchen
wer für mich arbeitet arbeitet gründlich
Ulrich von Heesen vielen Dank
Ulrich von Heesen so meine Damen und
Herren
ich könnte mir vorstellen ihr privater
Bedarf an schlechten Nachrichten ist im
Moment weitgehend gedeckt aber
übermorgen könnte die nächste kommen in
Italien wird gewählt und da ist wohl ein
Rechtsruck sagen Experten überaus
wahrscheinlich ja eine
ein Mitte rechtsbündnis aus
vorzeititalia Lega und fratelli d'Italia
hat beste Aussichten die italienische
Regierung zu bilden gemeinsam haben sie
neulich Mario Draghi gestürzt denn der
war kompetent und unbestechlich mit
anderen Worten nicht tragbar
wenn es blöd läuft heißt die
Ministerpräsidentin also bei Georgia
Meloni von den fratelli die sich in der
Tradition der italienischen Faschisten
sehen muss man sich Sorgen machen wenn
ich eine faschistin wäre dann würde ich
das sagen aber ich bin keine faschistin
sagt Georgia Meloni ja gut wenn Sie das
sagt ne ich meine
Faschisten sind ja sehr ehrliche
Menschen hört man wobei müssen wir dazu
sagen die Fratellis gelten offiziell als
Postfaschisten das ist bestimmt viel
besser meine Damen und Herren jedes Land
das sollten wir respektieren hat seine
eigenen Bräuche und in Italien waren die
Faschisten halt immer ziemlich gut
integriert die Urenkelin von Benito
Mussolini saß bis 2019 im
Europaparlament das hat Hitlers Enkel
nie geschafft ja weil der Führer zum
Glück nur einen Hoden hatte und keine
Kinder
meine klar wenn man sich die
Wahlveranstaltung der fratelli genau an
guckt sieht man da schon den ein oder
anderen römischen Gruß oder ja
vielleicht verstehe ich es noch falsch
ne fünf Ramazzotti bitte oder das kann
ja sein was würde eine
Ministerpräsidentin Meloni für Europa
bedeuten sie hat der Europäischen Union
bereits ausrichten lassen der Spaß sei
vorbei Zitat Ende ich wusste gar nicht
dass der angefangen hat welcher Spaß ich
möchte eine Europa in dem Brüssel nicht
Dinge tut die Rom besser kann sondern
ich möchte das Brüssel tut was Rom
alleine nicht kann zum Beispiel unsere
Rechnung bezahlen
Italien kriegt alleine unfassbare 192
Milliarden Euro aus dem Corona
Stabilisierungsfonds der EU trotzdem
wettert Meloni weiter gegen Brüssel und
natürlich gegen woknis und LG PTQ Terror
neulich haben sich ihre fratelli zum
Beispiel furchtbar aufgeregt weil in
einer Peppa Wutz Folge ein kleiner
Eisbär von seinen beiden Müttern erzählt
hat wie stellen die sich denn das ideale
Kinderfernsehen vor Peppa porco das
Fahrschule Pepper kommt aus der Schule
haben wir nicht was vergessen Pepper
wenn wir nach Hause kommen was machen
wir da den römischen Gruß Mama aber Mama
der sieht ja genauso aus wie der
Hitlergruß halt die Klappe dumme Schwein
das sind zwei völlig verschiedene Grüße
Papa pauka kommt von der Arbeit boah ich
habe den ganzen Tag Flüchtlinge
abgeschoben ich muss erstmal unter die
Dusche da lachen alle denn Dusche hieß
ein beliebter Politiker in Italien na
Pepper was habt ihr denn heute gelernt
in der Schule die Lehrerin hat gesagt
eine Familie kann auch zwei Mamas haben
und keinen Papa das finde ich toll wenn
das so ist kannst du hier leider nicht
mehr wohnen du wohnst ab jetzt bei Onkel
drin jetzt in Deutschland Ciao Mama
Peppa Pop
Peppa Wutz ganz bald auf euren
schulbrotkindern das ist aber vielleicht
alles auch kein Grund zur Aufregung
meine italienische Regierung halten im
Schnitt nur 14 Monate es geht doch auch
rum und wer weiß vielleicht wird sogar
ganz ulkig denn Meloni Sidekick ist hier
ein alter Bekannter Silvio Berlusconi
ist noch ein Begriff oder ja
der Mann mit der angetackerten
teppichfliese auf der Birne
ist politisch einfach nicht tot zu
kriegen obwohl er echt alles versucht
hat ernsthaft wer wählt den Domain
Houston
tree der Mann der ein ganzes Land
verzeihen sie fickte
mein Gott was ist bloß aus der Sendung
Kulturzeit geworden ein verfickter
Saustall meine Damen und Herren
sie sind mir völlig egal die sind eine
schnurz viel schlimmer ist seine
anhaltende Freundschaft mit Wladimir
Putin und auch Matteo salvinis leger
rühmt sich ihrer Kreml Kontakte also
jetzt ganz aktuell
natürlich nicht mehr so laut aber bis
neulich noch 2019 nannte Salvini
Vladimir Putin den ich zitiere besten
lebenden Staatsmann der Welt und auch
dieses extrem blöde Urlaubsfoto lässt
wenig Interpretationsspielraum sage ich
mal Putin arbeitet seit Jahren mit
finde sie lecker oder was Putin Putin
arbeitet seit Jahren mit viel Geld daran
die EU kaputt zu kriegen und wenn es
blöd läuft kommt er diesem Ziel am
Sonntag deutlich näher Europa wird ja
insgesamt rechter in Schweden sitzen
auch bald Rechtspopulisten in der
Regierung ist ja so ist ja so und wenn
es
wenn es Brüssel nicht mal schafft den
Rechtsstaat im kleinen Ungarn zu
verteidigen wird das in Italien erst
recht nicht klappen andererseits weiß
nicht wie es Ihnen geht aber Italien
kann ich nie lange böse sein dafür ist
es einfach zu schön und zu lecker ob
Mensch ich merke gerade ich bin schon
wieder in Urlaubsstimmung
Georgia Meloni präsentiert Italo Hits 88
freuen Sie sich auf die Populisten
Version des Klassikers felicita
wollen wir nicht in den Schulen mit
Lesben und Schwulen kein gender Gaga und
natürlich auf eros ramazzottis
insolventshymne
[Musik]
reicht nicht mal für eine Calzone
feiern sie Umberto Tozzi und seine
legendäre Gänsehaut Ballade
[Musik]
schlechte Laune garantiert Italo heads
88 nur 9,99 bzw ganz bald 300.000 lire
ja aber
Vorsicht vorsicht hier besteht
ausdrücklich kein Grund zur Arroganz die
Italiener haben zum Beispiel eine
übergewinnsteuer wir nicht und nicht nur
italienischer auch deutsche Parteien
pflegen ja weiter ihre Nähe zu Putins
Russland so hat gerade diese Woche eine
lustige afd-reisegruppe für Schlagzeilen
gesorgt herzlich Willkommen zu
sonnenklarot TV hallo hallo liebe
Weltenbummler die Herbstferien stehen
wieder vor der Tür und damit die alte
Frage wohin diesmal Radtour durch die
Pyrenäen und jeden Abend den Wunden
Köter mit Penatencreme einschmieren oder
doch eine Woche Dauerregen auf Usedom
mit Mutti und danach die Scheidung ja
das klingt alles total verlockend
Albrecht aber wie wäre es denn mal mit
was neuen also nimm wirklich originellen
Reiseziel mehrere Politiker der AFD sind
nach eigenen Angaben gerade in Russland
unterwegs und planen die von Russland
besetzte Ostukraine zu besuchen es soll
wohl in den dombas gehen
der Herbst Klassiker Indian Summer im
Don Bass oder wie man bei der AFD sagt
Indianersommer Albrecht bitte man sagt
nicht mehr AFD
man sagt indigene Idiot Patrioten
entschuldigung das war jedenfalls die
überraschendste Buchung des Jahres die
herrentierschneider blex und Wald vom
afd-flügel wollten sich angesichtszitat
verzerrender Berichterstattung ein
eigenes Bild von der Lage machen
eingeladen vom Putin Regime und das
finde ich eine ganz wunderbare Idee
tatsächlich möchten wir heute möglichst
viele afd-funktionäre aufrufen sich in
der umkämpften Ostukraine selbst ein
Bild zu machen ja ja täglich jetzt
anrufen und direkt buchen wir haben nur
noch wenige hunderttausend Plätze frei
und ja mit etwas Glück kostet Sie der
Flug nichts wie bei den drei Flitzpiepen
hier bezahlt vom Steuerzahler bzw der
AFD Landtagsfraktion Sachsen-Anhalt kurz
afdsa ja leider endete der romantik-trip
aber schon in Russland weil irgendwelche
Spaßbremsen aus der Partei Bedenken
hatten kriegstourismus ist wohl schlecht
fürs Image
wer hätte das gedacht ja komisch ja die
AFD hat ja sowieso gerade eine
Pechsträhne hier neulich im Wahlkampf
Kurzurlaub Landtagswahl Niedersachsen am
9 oktober hat die AFD jetzt Gummibärchen
und das Volk gebracht die kleinen Gummi
Süßigkeiten die den Pfeil im Parteilogo
der AFD darstellen sollen sehen aus wie
rote Penisse
du liebe
Güte Tüte Pimmel
das darf einer homophobenpartei aber
eigentlich nicht passieren das stimmt
auch deswegen auch deswegen reisen die
ja so gerne nach Russland weil sich da
ein autoritärer Herrscher eben nicht
durch Gendern lässt ich habe in der Tat
das Gefühl der Abgeordnete tilschneider
ist sogar ein kleines bisschen verknallt
wenn man allein schon Putin als als
Präsidenten ansieht und und beiden immer
diese Typen vergleicht ja in echter Kerl
ein richtiger Mann mit gesunden Werte
Gerüst und da eine giftige alte Kröte ja
Moment giftige alte Kröte ist das nicht
der Kosename von Beatrix von Storch
nein ist es nicht weil das wäre ja
frauenfeindlich also liebe afd-fans wer
jetzt noch Mallorca buchte hat den
Schuss nicht gehört Russland auf
Steuerzahlerkosten oder kriege ich
gerade rein eine exklusive Wellnessreise
nach Nordkorea
arioveda in Pjöngjang und demokratischer
geht es beim besten Willen nicht noch
ein afd-penis auch sehr gerne
wir sind aber weich ja klar
[Applaus]
wir haben gesagt die soll man den
Lieblingswitz erzählen was mache ich
gerne also kommen ein Pferd Jeff Bezos
und der Papst in eine Bar sagt der
Barkeeper abonniere endlich den
verkackten heute schon
Kanal also geht doch